this is Startalk scenario you're in an
elevator with a congressman who has a
lot of say over where tax money gets
spent you have one minute until the
elevator arrives at its destination what
examples of economic technological or
any other returns would you use to
convince him that space exploration is
worth funding more yes in with with a
minute to go I would say that it's going
to stimulate the economy mm-hmm with new
technology yeah new developments and the
science field it's coming new new new
discoveries and materials and medicines
and so on it helps education because it
inspires young people yeah and it
promotes international cooperation
because we have our international space
station right other science programs and
it gives us something for our future
it's about exploration in our future yes
by my reckoning you did it in 56 seconds
yeah nice right now onto my floor and
I'm on my way but bill what would you
say I'd say space exploration brings out
the best in us it's inherently
optimistic it stimulates the economy in
the u.s. at least three dollars and
sixty cents for every dollar that goes
in and we make discoveries that
literally change the world astronomy has
changed the world we found that the
earth goes around the Sun that changed
everything yeah we found the sun's not
unique first people are maybe punished
for it but yes but it did change the
world yeah now people throw around the
expression dark energy dark matter like
it's a day at the office but we all take
it for granted that there is such a
thing or such things and these were not
discovered even really fifteen years ago
who knows what new physics who knows
what it's over the next horizon and
Congressman if I made to speak as a guy
born in the US and as a patriot don't
you want the u.s. to continue to lead in
this thing isn't that what you want mr.
congressman yeah miss congressman